we have come together to witness the
marriage of Henry Charles Albert David
and Rachel mekin
to pray for God's blessing on them
the world watched with excitement as
prince harry married megan Markland st.
George's Chapel at Windsor Castle almost
one year ago now photographer Alexi
looper murski was there to capture the
official portraits of the royal couple
on their wedding day
goulburn-murray Sookie also took those
iconic engagement photos and now he's
got a new children's book it's called
thank you for my dreams bedtime prayers
of gratitude good morning - this is not
your first book we use we should say
you've been doing this before I have the
table but I got a little goose-bumpy
just looking at that video and listen
Alexi you were there inside the church
can you believe it's been a year I know
it's been crazy it seems like yesterday
now we're all waiting for the baby have
they asked you to do the baby photo no
you know last time I could go the first
time I came on the show I'd only done
the engagement and I didn't know about
the wedding ones so it's the same
situation now if they call me a
fantastic wonderful they call you you
can figure out a way to get to the you
to get to Windsor yes lickety-split
exactly so let's talk about your book I
love the title thank you for my dreams
and I love the first thing that starts
with thank you for letting us wake up
every morning when we feel happy and
healthy I think everybody in this room
said that today but you said even for
yourself saying thank you came to you in
your 20s what do you mean you know you
notice how your body reacts when you
start to feel depressed or sad or angry
about something and I wanted to switch
it and so I started saying thank you and
focusing a couple of minutes on two
things I was grateful for and you
immediately notice the change in your in
your your demeanor and the problem will
still be there but you hurt you're
better but in a better space to deal
with it but then your four-year-old son
heard you well yes so in the last decade
of my my two year my two sons have been
watching me meditate and then do my
thank yous in the morning and they
wanted to know what I was doing so I
started incorporating them into the
practice and at the beginning I was a
bit difficult for them to think of more
than two or three things clay thank you
for is usually thank you for mommy and
daddy thanks for my chocolate chip
cookies my car my toys lying and after a
few months they got more and more fluent
until one night we were in holiday and
they started saying a thank yous and
they didn't stop and he went on for
hours
so I started active I've got to write
this down this is amazing and so yeah
actually I was just a secretary on this
job they wrote so all of these are there
yeah and it's also they've studied this
and the gratitude before bedtime
actually has a measure
measurable impressive ones outlook in
life so this is now hardwired into your
kids behaviors not just before bedtime
but in everything and that it's really
about sort of saying thankful being
thankful for things that we take for
granted every day so like for example
thank you for your eyes so you can see
everything beautiful in the world thank
you for your legs so you can run thank
you for your ear so you can hear your
loved ones voices just things that
everyday thing but this is a very smart
little child who said this thank you for
making me patient when I keep trying to
do something that doesn't work like when
I was learning to ride a bicycle and
kept hurting myself how's my eldest son
yeah that's a very smart thing and
someone else said thank you for people
not using plastic straws
my son's a geek I worry my wife Giada
she has a thing called eco shaker and
she the massive environmentalist so our
sons are hardwired into that as well how
does that gratitude sort of work in your
in your daily professional life I mean
your photography is spectacular thank
you and you photograph some of those
famous people in the world but it's not
an easy job no what but but it's a
fantastic job you know I mean I'm so
blessed to do what I do I get to travel
around the world I get to take pictures
of fascinating people in beautiful
dresses and beautiful locations I mean
what's not to be thankful and we should
say as we're talking to you Sky News is
reporting that Megan is in labor sitting
here talking now what off the press yeah
how doctor press and how did you how did
you find both of them what kind of
parents do you think they'll be I think
it'd be amazing listen they're just a
beautiful young couple in love they got
their heads screwed on straight and they
can be amazing it's gonna be very
exciting to see what how it all turns
out why we're excited I know are you
still on a high because that that that
picture that you took of the whole
family with the Queen there did you
really not feel any pressure any
nervousness knowing that the Queen and
Prince Phillip are their little kids and
to get everybody looking straight at the
camera at the same time good idea but it
was you know he's one of those things
you you you go in there and sort of fake
until you make it and I was just saying
right everybody was the camera come on
let's do it let's do it and yeah well
she's in labor now it'll either be a boy
or a girl
I'm hoping for a boy I like a big older
brother hoping for that Thank You Alexi
do pomorskie good to have you here thank
you thank you for my dreams is what it's
called it's on sale tomorrow wherever
you like to buy your books we'll be
right back